¿Por qué debería importarte Georgia?
Podríamos decir que es la precuela de lo que ha
sido la guerra de Ucrania. Muchos antes de que
Putin invadiera Crimea, los georgianos ya habían
recibido la visita de los tanques rusos. De hecho,
todavía hoy en día, Rusia controla de facto dos
regiones de este país: ABJASIA y OSETIA DEL SUR.
Y antes, mucho antes de que Zelensky se
convirtiera en el enemigo número 1 de Putin,
Mijail Saakashvili era quien ocupaba
este puesto. Y, creedme, hablamos de
odio de verdad. Atentos a las palabras de Putin.
(Vladimir Putin ha amenazado con colgar "de las
pelotas" al líder de Georgia. The Telegraph)
Si sois veteranos seguidores de VisualPolitik
ya sabéis de quién hablo. Si no lo sois,
os presento a uno de los personajes más
fascinantes de la política internacional.
Siempre he pensado que, si hubiera sido
americano, tendría ya 4 series en Netflix.
Mijail Saakashvili fue presidente de Georgia. Bajo
su mandato, la economía georgiana despegó y esta
república ex sov iética se acercó a Occidente más
que nunca. Tras perder las elecciones, renunció
a su nacionalidad georgiana… ¡Y se hizo ciudadano
ucraniano! Ya en Ucrania, llegó a ser gobernador
de Odesa. Incluso Zelensky le llegó a nombrar
Director del Consejo Nacional de Reformas. Pero,
en 2021, decidió volver a su Georgia natal.
¡Y no creáis que se fue en avión como una persona
normal! Cruzó la frontera escondido en el trailer
de un camión de productos lácteos ¿Por qué? Pues
porque tenía una orden de detención en Georgia.
Eso significa que, en cualquier control
fronterizo, se lo podrían llevar preso.
¡Habéis oído bien! Saakashvili no deja
a nadie indiferente. Muchos georgianos
todavía le apoyan. Otros le odian.
Entre otros, los que controlan el país.
(Estoy encarcelado por un régimen
que está usando mi cautividad para
contentar a Vladimir Putin - Mikheil Saakashvili)
El caso es que nada más llegar fue
detenido y mandado ipso facto a prisión,
tanto por entrar ilegalmente en el país como
por otros seis delitos que tenía pendientes.
Desde entonces su estado de salud ha empeorado
drásticamente. Parte es por las huelgas de
hambre que ha protagonizado. Pero también hay
indicios de cosas mucho más preocupantes. Atentos.
N2(En nuevas grabaciones, el expresidente
georgiano y enemigo de Putin denuncia malos
tratos en medio de acusaciones de
que está siendo envenenado. Forbes)
Pero lo más importante de esta historia es que es
el síntoma de algo mucho más grande: Georgia está
tendiendo puentes con el Kremlin. Y la pregunta es
¿Por qué? Pensadlo así: hablamos de un país que,
de facto, tiene territorios invadidos por Rusia.
Un país que ha recibido a miles de rusos que
escapaban del régimen de Putin ¿Cómo es posible
que tengan tan buenas relaciones con Moscú?
¿Son ciertas las conexiones entre Moscú
y el partido Sueño Georgiano que está
en el poder? ¿Qué implicaciones puede
tener la guerra de Ucrania en todo esto?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
T1(LA ODISEA GEORGIANA)
Muchos de vosotros seguro que sabéis
que Georgia fue parte de la Unión Soviética,
pero lo que seguro que no tantos sabéis es
que uno de los líderes soviéticos más importantes
de toda la historia nació y vivió en este lugar.
¿Alguna idea? ¿Adivináis de quién estamos
hablando? Pues si, ni más ni men os que de
Iosif Stalin. Pero no nos adelantemos, porque
antes de que Georgia fuera parte de la URSS,
lo fue de otros imperios.
Desde la antigua Grecia y
el Imperio Romano hasta los persas y otomanos, el
territorio de Georgia estuvo casi bajo control de
alguna potencia extranjera. Estos territorios
estuvieron unificados y fueron relativamente
prósperos entre el siglo X y el siglo XII, pero
a partir de ahí y prácticamente hasta el siglo
XIX todo fueron invasiones y saqueos.
De hecho, la situación era tan mala,
que los principados en los que se dividía la
actual Georgia pidieron incluso integrarse en
Rusia para conseguir protección. Y, por
supuesto, lo consiguieron… Ahora bien,
¿A qué precio? Pues a uno bastante elevado, porque
las campañas de rusificación comenzaron casi de
inmediato. Esto alimentó el nacionalismo local lo
que condujo, junto al golpe de estado bolchevique
en Rusia de 1917, a declarar la independencia
georgiana en 1917. Claro que esto no duró mucho
tiempo. Apenas 4 años más tarde, en 1921, la Unión
Soviética volvió a anexionar este territorio.
(Entonces, la nueva Georgia soviética
comenzó a experimentar una cierto proceso
de industrialización y urbanización, pero también
sufrió duramente la represión típica del Estado
soviético y las campañas de homogeneización
cultural y étnica. Un proceso que se extendió
hasta 1991 cuándo el colapso de la URSS volvió
a dar paso a la independencia de Georgia.
Sin embargo, otra odisea
estaba a punto de empezar.
Nada más conseguir la independencia empezaron a
surgir todo tipo de problemas: una guerra civil,
conflictos étnicos en Abjasia y Osetia del Sur,
una durísima crisis económica, etcétera, etcétera.
Con semejante percal el oligarca
soviético Eduard Shevardnadze,
el último ministro de Exteriores
de la mismísima Unión Soviética,
fue puesto por los militares al frente
del país tras un golpe de Estado en 1992.
Al principio sus datos no fueron malos: logró
terminar con la guerra civil en 1995 y la
economía comenzó a mejorar ligeramente después
de que el PIB cayera un 78% entre 1991 y 1995.)
Sin embargo, los problemas se fueron acumulando:
un 50% de la población no llegaba a fin de mes,
la corrupción seguía campando a sus
anchas por todas las esquinas y el
autoritarismo se había convertido en la
característica fundamental del gobierno.
Al final, después de amenazar y coaccionar
a la cadena de televisión Rustavi 2 y ser
acusado de amañar las elecciones, llegó el
acontecimiento que transformaría Georgia: la
Revolución de las Rosas. Y, ¿quién lideraba esta
revolución? Exacto, nuestro amigo Saakashvili.
Saakashvili, abogado de profesión y exministro
de justicia del propio Shevardnadze, se rebeló
contra el que fue su padrino político y acabó
exigiendo su dimisión en su propio despacho.
Al final, entre la presión ejercida por sus
propios círculos y por las protestas en las
calles, Shevardnadze se vió obligado a
tirar la toalla y abandonar el poder.
En 2004, Saakashvili ganó las elecciones
presidenciales por una mayoría abrumadora.
Y a partir de ahí… Bueno, digamos que
el país dio un vuelco de 180 grados:
las medidas anticorrupción hicieron que
Georgia avanzara en unos pocos años del
puesto 133 al 51 en 2012 en transparencia, al
tiempo que las reformas espolearon la economía.
En cierto modo el país se trazó un objetivo muy
claro: convertirse en una especie de Edén liberal
en materia económica: para ello el gobierno de
Saakashvili hizo todo lo que os podéis esperar,
e incluso más: introdujo una regulación
laboral flexible, bajo los aranceles,
bajos los impuestos, redujo la burocracia y
abrió al exterior, particularmente a Occidente.
Sin embargo, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
no es oro todo lo que reluce. Los gobiernos de
Saakashvili tenían otra cara: pronto surgieron
denuncias sobre ataques a la libertad de prensa,
represión a partidos de la oposición y nuevos
casos de corrupción. Todo esto hizo que el propio
Saakashvili dimitiera en 2007 para volver a ganar
las elecciones apenas un año más tarde en 2008.
Sin embargo, durante su segundo mandato,
aunque las reformas económicas continuaron, las
acusaciones volvieron a repetirse. Y lo que es aún
peor, en 2008 sufrió el ataque militar de Rusia.
(En 2008, tras una serie de enfrentamientos
entre las fuerzas independentistas de Osetia
del Sur y campesinos que se identificaban como
georgianos, en una decisión quizás incomprensible
Saakashvili movilizó al ejército para poner
fin de una vez por todas a la violencia de
los separatistas apoyados por Rusia.
Y vaya la que se lió. El Kremlin vio
la oportunidad. Acusó al gobierno georgiano de
querer llevar a cabo una limpieza étnica lo que
supuestamente justificaba su intervención. Ya
sabéis, es algo de lo que ya os hemos hablado
en este canal:la doctrina Karaganov, que
básicamente consiste en que Rusia tiene
que ser el protector de los ciudadanos
de etnia rusa en los países de su órbita.
Esta es, sin ir más lejos, la excusa que
ha utilizado Rusia para invadir Ucrania
en dos ocasiones, primero en 2014 cuando se
anexionó Crimea y luego otra vez en 2022.
Y por supuesto también es la excusa que
puso para atacar e invadir Georgia..
En 2008 las tropas rusas llegaron a territorio
georgiano y avanzaron hasta llegar a 40 km
de su capital, Tiflis, al tiempo que la
fuerza aérea dañó objetivos estratégicos..
Finalmente, llegaron a un alto al fuego apenas un
par de semanas después del comienzo del conflicto
y entonces Rusia reconoció oficialmente la
independencia de Abjasia y Osetia del Sur.)
Queridos amigos, Saakashvili fracasó en su promesa
de restaurar la integridad territorial de Georgia.
Y, para colmo, sus medidas no estaban resolviendo
con urgencia otro de los grandes problemas del
país: los bajos sueldos y las bajas pensiones.
Así que en las elecciones presidenciales de
2013 Saakashvili decidió presentarse
y su partido recibió un duro castigo:
un nuevo actor político se llevó todo el
protagonismo. Estamos hablando, por supuesto,
del Sueño Georgiano.
Atentos.
T2(EL SUEÑO LÚCIDO DEL MULTIMILLONARIO SOVIÉTICO)
Nacido en 2012, el Sueño Georgiano
ha dominado la política georgiana
desde entonces hasta nuestros días. Con una
posición más escorada al centro-izquierda,
ha sido acusado en reiteradas ocasiones de
blanquear en el país a la Rusia de Putin.
Este partido no podría haber llegado hasta
donde está sin el impulso de su fundador:
el multimillonario Bidzina Ivanishvili.
Así que, si queremos echar un vistazo a las
acusaciones que se le hacen sobre sus nexos
con Rusia, lo primero que tenemos que
hacer es conocer mejor a Ivanishvili.
Hablamos del hombre más rico de Georgia.
Un tipo que hizo su fortuna en Rusia con
negocios muchas veces más que cuestionables
y que regresó a su país natal tras el éxito
de la Revolución de las Rosas. Incluso en su
día apoyó al propio Saakashvili.. Un apoyo que
duró hasta el 2011 cuándo empezó a poner en
marcha su propio proyecto político: hablamos,
por supuesto, del Sueño Georgiano,
el partido que ganó por mayoría las
elecciones parlamentarias del 2012. Lo que
le valió convertirse en el Primer Ministro.
Y aunque, de repente, apenas un año después
decidió dejar su cargo, lo cierto es que se
mantuvo como presidente, dueño y señor de
su partido. Pocos dudas en Georgia de que
Ivanishvili es quien maneja todos los hilos.
Sea como sea, la cuestión es que el Sueño
Georgianoo ha cobrado especial importancia en los
últimos tiempos. ¿Por qué motivo? Pues porque su
posición frente a Rusia es totalmente diferente
a la que hubiera tenido el bueno de Saakashvili.
El partido del multimillonario georgiano ha
adoptado un discurso mucho menos agresivo con
Rusia tras su criminal invasión de Ucrania.
¿Por qué? Pues quizás por el temor a que la
economía del país se estanque todavía más si
se enfrenta a Rusia. Porque, amigos, amigas, si
hablamos de economía los últimos años no han sido
particularmente buenos y al final, Rusia, pues,
¿Qué queréis qué os diga? Es un importante
socio comercial para Georgia. Fijaos.
Como veis, Rusia es el segundo mayor
mercado para las exportaciones de Georgia y,
es también su segundo proveedor más importante.
Quizás eso explique porque este gobierno ha
recibido tantas acusaciones de blanquear
las acciones de Rusia y menospreciar sus
relaciones con la Unión Europea.
Y desde luego, noticias como
esta no ayudan precisamente a su imagen.
N3(El Sueño Georgiano anula el acuerdo de
"19 de abril" del Consejo de la UE. Georgia Today)
Claro que no hablamos de acusaciones estrictamente
nuevas. En 2019 ya se produjo un gran revuelo
cuando Sueño Georgiano invitó a un parlamentario
comunista ruso, Sergei Gavrilov, al Parlamento.
Y si esto ya esto levantaba sospechas,
cuando Gavrilov se sentó en la silla del
Presidente del Parlamento y empezó a dar
un discurso en ruso sobre la unión de Rusia y
Georgia, entonces los georgianos estallaron.
Las protestas exigiendo dimisiones brotaron en las
calles. Y ya de paso, la oposición comenzó a pedir
una reforma electoral para que los resultados de
las elecciones fueran totalmente proporcionales.
Y, ¿qué creéis que pasó? Pues
que, contra todo pronóstico,
consiguieron la dimisión del Presidente del
Parlamento y, también, la reforma electoral.
Lo más sorprendente de todo, es que pese
a todas las manifestaciones y escándalos
el partido sigue ganando las elecciones.
Y para colmo justo cuando su imagen estaba
más deteriorada, estalló la pandemia… Y aquí
hay que decir que una amplia mayoría de la
población considera que la gestión que
se hizo de la pandemia fue buena o muy
buena. Inc reíble pero cierto, Georgia
es uno de esos pocos países dónde la
Covid 19 lejos de castigar al gobierno,
le supuso todo un chute de popularidad.
Y de esta forma en 2021 volvieron a
ganar las elecciones locales - eso sí,
con muchas acusaciones de fraude e
intimidación en los centros de votación.
Sea como sea, la guerra de Ucrania lo ha
cambiado todo. El cómo el Sueño Georgiano
afronté este nuevo reto… Es algo que puede ser
determinante para su supervivencia… Y clave para
el futuro del país.
Atentos.
T3(¿LA PESADILLA GEORGIANA O EL MILAGRO RUSO?)
No es ninguna sorpresa que el conflicto entre
Rusia y Ucrania ha salpicado a Georgia. Y no
precisamente porque se hayan visto envueltos
en el mismo, sino porque este país ha recibido
cientos de miles de exiliados que huyen de
las consecuencias de la guerra. Pero, ojo,
porque no hablamos de exiliados ucranianos… Fijaos
N4(Los rusos que huyen de la guerra de
Putin añaden una nueva tensión a las
viejas tensiones en la cercana Georgia
Los rusos que huyen a Georgia del
reclutamiento para la guerra de Ucrania
están agravando las tensiones existentes desde
hace generaciones entre ambos países. USA Today)
Exacto, hablamos de los exiliados rusos que se
han marchado porque o bien se oponen a la guerra,
o bien no quieren correr el riesgo de
ser reclutados para luchar en el frente.
Y sí, mayoritariamente son esas personas
las que están llegando a Georgia. De hecho,
desde el comienzo de la guerra hasta el anuncio
del reclutamiento masivo de Putin en septiembre,
cerca de 40.000 rusos se trasladaron a Georgia.
Pero, ¿sabéis qué? Justo después de que
se anunciara la movilización parcial,
¡Cientos de miles de rusos llegaron de repente
a este pequeño país! De todos ellos se estima
que unos 100.000 se han quedado a residir
en Georgia. Es decir, casi un 3% de toda la
población georgiana en apenas unas pocas semanas.
Georgia todavía no llega a los niveles de países
como Estonia donde los refugiados
ucranianos, ya suponen alrededor del
5% de la población pre-guerra, pero aún
así hablamos de una cifra muy relevante.
Ahora la cuestión es que esta llegada
masiva de población rusa está teniendo
para Georgia un efecto tanto positivo
como negativo. Fijaos en esta tabla.
(Una buena parte de todos los profesionales
que han huido de Rusia tienen perfiles
altamente cualificados, especialmente en
lo que respecta al sector tecnológico,
y ahora Georgia se está beneficiando de ello.
De hecho, hasta en los pequeños pueblos
más pobres y recónditos de Georgia se ha
experimentado un cierto boom económico,
aunque solo sea porque les venden a
los rusos direcciones postales para que
puedan establecer en ellas sus negocios.
En total, se calcula que los rusos que
han llegado a Georgia han emprendido ya
unos 10.000 negocios en el país..
Y, de hecho, a lo largo de 2022 la
entrada de capitales a Georgia tuvo
efectos significativos. Por ejemplo,
las reservas de divisas internacionales del país
se incrementaron un 12,2 por ciento hasta los
4.900 millones de dólares, y el Iari,
la moneda local, se apreció un 13%.)
Claro que, no todo resulta tan bueno. Los
georgianos no se han olvidado aún de lo que
Rusia les hizo en 2008, y el hecho de que el 20%
del territorio nacional siga estando bajo dominio
ruso, desde luego, no ayuda. Así que muchos de
los rusos que han llegado ahora sufren numerosos
casos de discriminación. Y, por supuesto, terminan
pagando justos por pecadores. Incluso los rusos
que están en contra de Putin están sufriendo
una situación que amenaza la paz social.
Claro que ese no es el único problema. La
llegada de rusos también está alimentando
una enorme escasez de viviendas. Los
rusos necesitan encontrar un lugar
para vivir… Lo que es pura gasolina para la
demanda inmobiliaria. Pero eso no es todo,
como hablamos en muchos casos de profesionales con
ingresos relativamente altos, pues lógicamente,
están dispuestos a pagar mucho más por esas
viviendas… Lo que multiplica el problema.
Para que os hagáis una idea, desde
que diera comienzo la guerra Ucrania,
los precios de los alquileres en Tiflis
se han disparado. Algunas estimaciones
hablan de incrementos del precio de los
alquileres de hasta el 210%. Por su parte,
el precio de las viviendas en propiedad se
incrementó un 28% en comparación con 2021.
En cualquier caso, a pesar de las tensiones en
su mercado inmobiliario, en términos generales
creo que podemos decir que Georgia está saliendo
beneficiada de la llegada de los exiliados rusos.
¿Y sabéis qué? Esto nos lleva
directamente a una cuestión clave:
ahora que Rusia está sufriendo enormes pérdidas
militares en Ucrania y su fuerza está debilitada,
mientras que Georgia está aparentemente
fortaleciéndose…. ¿Se atreverá Tiflis a reclamar
los territorios invadidos en 2008?
Pues siento defraudarte pero lo más seguro es
que no. ¿Por que digo esto? Pues entre otras cosas
porque cuando Rusia invadió Ucrania a principios
de 2022, el gobierno del Sueño Georgiano
condenó el acto, pero no se sumó a las sanciones
internacionales contra el régimen de Putin.
Y, por supuesto, no debemos olvidar el tamaño
del ejército ruso. Claro, muchos estaréis diciendo
que tampoco es para tanto, mira cómo les va a los
ucranianos. Pero, queridos amigos, no confundáis
el tamaño del ejército ucraniano, que es uno de
los 15 más grandes del mundo, con el georgiano,
que es más bien modesto. Entre otras cosas porque
este país apenas tiene 3,7 millones de habitantes.
Y, tampoco olvidemos que Georgia hace frontera
con la Chechenia de Kadyrov y que no está
protegida por la OTAN. Es decir, el punto de
partida de Georgia es mucho peor que el de otras
pequeñas repúblicas ex-soviéticas como Estonia,
Letonia o Lituania que sí pueden actuar
con mucha más libertad e independencia.
Por lo tanto, lo más probable es que el Sueño
Georgiano no quiera complicarse demasiado la vida
después de la pandemia y busque recoger los frutos
del exilio ruso y llegado el caso, ¿quien sabe?
Quizás incluso sacar beneficio de convertirse
en una especie de puente para que Rusia se salte
algunas de las sanciones occidentales… Lo que,
por supuesto, podría acabar definitivamente con el
viejo sueño georgiano de integrarse en Occidente.
Pero, dicho esto ahora la pregunta es
para todos vosotros. ¿Creéis que Georgia debería
alinearse con Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea
y secundar las sanciones contra Rusia? ¿Logrará
sacar rendimiento económico de la guerra?
¿Seguirán pasando por alto los georgianos la
delicada situación de Saakashvili? Podéis dejarnos
vuestras opiniones aquí abajo, en los comentarios.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí en
VisualPolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribíos a este canal
y dadle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones. Si
os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos
vemos en el próximo. Un saludo y hasta pronto.